you say mine is high level
but it is not so
look it's not a main level no matter you
cable is correct
is correct or whether the largest plus 2 is correct
the tidal is that you found Jesus
that's already big
that is the tidal that is very big
see what after is what what what was in the past
for example my past was 1 criminal past
yes that does not make my testimony Great
the what is against me
Great is that I finally found Jesus
that that is Great
because the word says
the the smiley ways
to many can't find it
you have to go to the disco Brian
discover you must discover it
you have to do the roads
that to
who looks like Jesus who looks like life
is narrow and you have to discover it and be little
the people who discover it
yes well if you
the discovery thereof that is the drawn
that I was 1 criminal
is something that you can show something of
you you can do it but mine is drawn
what what what makes it very big
is that I am converted
knock knock knock because if you and you
and you too may not have had a criminal background
no no no some people
yes some people maybe had them at all
not a criminal in his background
well educated to school to work
good job good job diploma
never to whom it rooted
never smoked cigarette
never done nothing
but you didn't have Jesus in your life
and now that you have Jesus in your life
that is the one drawn
it is the one drawn
is that you went from death to life
no that's right that's the drawn
it is not about
some people think
ah I don't have to accept Jesus because I
ik my life is not like your life was
i i
I never stole it
I did not steal candy
I never lied
i was the day when you get home
eaten on time
to bed on time
could finish my school
so I'm all right
look at that calculator what did that calculator say to Jesus
yes i have done everything
Jesus said yes you have to
you need to do this
you must that man said I have done everything
Jesus GO against him and sell everything
well it can't do that
it cannot do that
where is you drawn then
yes you are not signed
yes I HAVE keep all the commandments
yes so then
then of course he actually had the money above god
he was not
he was unable to convert unreal
unreal follow Jesus
so never
never indeed try to belittle your titilation
no like it's not 1 big deal
no like it's not 1 big one
event is
yes it is the greatest event in your life ever
yes certainly greatest
greatest
because it is god's grace
that you know Jesus
yes if it is not by god's grace
that he opened your eyes
you would never discover him
yes you would